he holds up this bottle
to me
and
you know I'm I'm saying did you drink
this whole thing
something stupid
focusing on this detail and he
is telling me that I can't control him
anymore and
that if I really you know if I really
wanted to try take it and then he's like
taunting me to take the bottle from him
if I really if I really want him to stop
why don't I why don't I take it from him
go on go on kept saying go on
and kind of gesturing with the the
bottle towards me
and uh like team does that two or three
times I reached for it he'd revoke it
kind of laugh at me
and he's holding out the bottle I think
like maybe the third time or so I get a
hold of it
I'd pick it up and I slam it down on the
ground right in between us
there's a tile floor a white tile floor
and I smashed the bottle on the floor
and that really set him off
so stupid
um
sorry he's
um it was like a light bulb switch went
off
and he started screaming
um
I don't know if he backhanded me or hit
me normally I don't I don't really
recall but I remember it sent me down to
the ground
um I Remember by the time I picked
myself off the floor I stand up
he's got a bottle on his hand
and he threw it at me
it missed thankfully but I kind of
pulled myself back into the bar area
I don't know how much time passed but at
some point he had a broken bottle
up against my face neck area by my
jawline and
he told me he'd carve up my face
I don't know at what point in the
evening I couldn't tell you what
sequence
wise when that happened but it was
terrifying it wasn't the first time he
said that to me he said that to me on
the plane as well
um but this time he was holding a broken
bottle
to me
uh
I I honestly don't remember if I um
through anything in his Direction I
don't think I did I just remember
him having me by the nightgown
I remember him flailing me or throwing
me around I'm flailing
um
this is
after there were some bottles broken on
the floor I think this is actually after
again
forgive me I wish I could remember the
sequence but it's flashes
he's throwing these bottles at me I
remember retreating there were also cans
like soda cans beer or soda cans
and they're coming at me one after the
other and I keep pulling myself into the
bar area there's a bar behind me in
like a I don't know like an L shape
though he's standing the only way you
can exit so I'm kind of Trapped in front
of the sink
surrounded by bar on three sides with
him in front of me ish kind of front off
to this off to the left and he's
throwing these bottles one after the
other and
I can feel glass breaking behind me
I remember feeling
um one of them go by my head really fast
I mean the velocity a real velocity
I remember being terrified
I remember I couldn't move I couldn't go
anywhere
um
eventually I'm trying to I don't know if
you ran out of things to throw I think
that's how I move myself towards the
exit
and I believe that's most likely when we
got
kind of in this struggle by the bar
area
because I remember my feet slipping on
the tile as he was slamming me from
the wall
to the countertops
one point he has me up against the the
wall and he's punching the wall
he um had my
you know nightgown and it kind of ripped
it off my chest
I remember at one point he's teasing me
taunting me that I he has my
um my breasts and his hands
my nightgown came completely off it was
ripped off of me
I was naked
and I'm slipping around on this tile
and trying to get my footing and I
remember slipping on this tile glasses
underneath me and I remember just trying
to get my footing you know I felt really
destabilized and felt
really vulnerable I'm naked
he's flinging me around and at some
point
I'm up against the wall and he's
screaming at me that he [ __ ] hates me
and it ruined his life
Johnny became um
upset with me for judging him
he he was
you know
I couldn't it was like I couldn't win if
I didn't do anything if I didn't say
anything to him about the drinking if I
didn't acknowledge it it got worse if I
did acknowledge it it was my fault and I
was nagging
and I get it um you know I wouldn't like
to be told what to do either so but it
made him really angry and the kids were
in in the on this press tour and I was
just concerned about them I was
concerned about them hearing us
Johnny screamed at me in the hotel room
and only to think where the kids were in
an adjoining room
what if they could hear us you know I
had just met them and I didn't want them
to think
poorly at me and hate me not knowing
what was going on you know in our behind
closed doors I I just um
I remember and
it was name calling and he eventually
passed out do you recall what names he
called you do you recall what he said uh
I heard at this time nagging [ __ ]
nagging [ __ ] all the time called me
uh he even said that he made a mistake
uh with me and
that he didn't want to that when we
touched back down
he'd get rid of me and I'd go back to
it
maybe you said some disgusting things to
me I don't know if I need to repeat it
when you dropped me off in London we had
a few days
at this hotel that
we first
you know like consummated our
relationship in you know as a when we
were on the London press tour
and our relationship
developed
um that was the same hotel we were in
this same room which is a Johnny
like to be in the same room
and it was really sweet he got down on
one knee and
said I want you to be my girl be my girl
forever My Woman My Girl
I want you to be the rest of my life say
yes to me
uh he said he wanted to spend every
every day uh
he promised me that every day when I
woke up that I would wake up and he
would make me smile at least once
and that would be his goal
and
you know I I looked into
his eyes and I saw
my future
hope you know like blind hope so in love
nice it was one of the most
I can't describe that kind of joy you
know I thought
you know if we were married then
this is real this is real this isn't a
thing of
this isn't chaotic and this will change
you know I just I had so much hope in
that moment
um and I just said to him over and over
again are you serious are you are you
serious are you sure because you didn't
have a ring so I thought is this an
Impulse thing you know my experience
Johnny could be very impulsive and
uh he
uh he said over and over again be my be
my be my woman forever I want you to be
my wife my wife my wife
um I of course cried and we had a
wonderful evening and
I still he left shortly after and I was
like the next day I had to go to work
and it was just I couldn't tell anyone
and I wasn't sure part of me was worried
that he didn't mean it or you know or or
that he wasn't sure I just didn't want
it to be an Impulse thing so I didn't
want to mention it I want to bring it up
I didn't want to
um and and I kind of felt I walked
around for a few days like I had
butterflies
under my skin and
then my he brought my dad out to London
with my best friends and my dad told me
you know uh
Johnny is asked me permission for your
hand in marriage
and
I I felt like the luckiest woman in the
world
at some point in this get up
and move to the front of the planet I
remember getting up so slowly
I didn't want to aggravate him I didn't
want to give him any excuse to pounce on
I didn't want to upset him I didn't want
him
to flip a switch and get worse I didn't
want I just remember
very slow movements and I slowly get up
and move to the front of the plane and
he starts throwing things at me ice
cubes utensils
he's calling me a
um a go-getter and then an embarrassment
talking about what an embarrassment I am
I don't know how many times I moved
seats I wish I did
I don't I remember moving more than once
and Johnny came to me each time not the
other way around
he sits down in front of me at one point
and because I'm not answering him I was
looking out of the window
and he slaps my face
and
his friend
is in our proximity
and I it didn't hurt me it didn't hurt
my face it just felt embarrassed
did he do that to me in front of people
it was the first time that anything like
that had happened in front of somebody